la police a perquisitionné lundi ce
bureau de tabac à dijon elle ya trouvé
plusieurs sachets de fleurs de cannabis
ainsi que des fioles de liquide à base
de canne à biegen destiné aux vapo taj
les produits ont été saisis et détruits
le gérant placé en garde à vue pour
vente de produits dérivés du cannabis a
été depuis remis en liberté sans être
poursuivi car comme d'autres bureaux de
tabac c'est en toute bonne foi qu'il a
été amené à vendre ses nouveaux produits
présentés en tant que tel par le
fournisseur
certains les ont vite retirée de la
vente car dès le 13 juin dernier la
confédération des buralistes les a
alertés en publiant ce communiqué elle
leur recommandait de ne plus vendre de
cbd tant que la réglementation ne serait
pas éclaircies alors que le prix du
paquet de cigarettes doit être porté de
7 à 10 euros d'ici 2020 les buralistes
sont en pleine transformation
diversification de leurs commerces
ils y sont encouragés mais le cadre
légal en france est très stricte toute
commercialisation de produits contenant
du thc la substance psychotrope du
cannabis même très faiblement dosées est
prohibé il n'y a pas de cannabis légal
en france